[Music]
i've mentioned extensively my love of
bad reality shows
but there was a show about 10 years ago
i think
that christian and i used to watch on
the playboy channel we actually got the
channel specifically to watch this show
it was called foursome
they took two men and two women and just
allowed them to kind of run amok in a
house for an evening one of the male
contestants had this funny
characteristic where he would exhale
through his nose
he was meeting for the first time one of
the female contestants if you've ever
seen little shot before as she looked a
little bit like ellen green and that she
had a like big poof of blonde hair and
she had this voice like this she
literally sounded like this
when he first met her he said
it's nice to meet you so tell me
something about yourself
breathe through his nose
and then she said chris you want to do
it like what i like whiskey sours
it's the funniest moment in television
history life could be a dream
life could be a dream
this is justin long and you are
listening to life is short life could be
a dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is christian long
hello oh wow that well we said it the
same exactly
wow so uh we should clarify
the show a little bit it was
i don't know that i described it also
the more you say like nervous to
describe the more you protest about why
you
why you subscribe to the playboy channel
sounds like a lie guiltier that's true
that's true well but it i i can confirm
that that is that show foursome this
reality show on the playboy channel was
the sole reason
the only thing we watched on it yeah
absolutely i know again i sound like i'm
being defensive i swear i swear i don't
like nudity
so this guy who asked this question in
this self-conscious nerdy way he had
such self-consciousness in his voice and
that nose blow is it just indicates his
awkwardness
our guest today is
perhaps the polar opposite of that
person yeah so our guest today is kevin
bacon who is got such an ease about him
i mean among other other things but
there's something so cool about him so
naturally
cool about him in in so far as he
doesn't
try at all and there's nothing forced
about it yeah even when he came into the
studio he was running late if i'm
running late which i often am for an
appointment it sends me into like this
apologetic tizzy i'm so sorry and like
explaining and and he seemed genuinely
apologetic about it
but he was one or two lines of hey i'm
sorry there's a lot of traffic it's a
perfect apology it was a cool apology it
was cool there's cared about it but he
didn't indulge in it he's also a guy
who's so
famous so well known there's a game
about how famous he is six degrees of
kevin bacon and that whole game is about
how you can connect any actor to kevin
bacon
uh in six degrees basically so it's like
give an example it's like uh how do you
connect kevin bacon to jeremy reiner
jeremy renner can you do it uh yeah okay
so
jeremy renner to the avengers
to
oh jeremy renner was in mission
impossible with tom cruise and tom
cruise was then a few good men with nice
kevin bacon two degrees
wow he's been a famous actor for 35
years he was in god everything i mean
friday the 13th of apollo 13.
so many iconic movies i think that's
when we get into that the game and why
the game was created and the big
challenge for me that i faced in this
interview was to not gush as much as
i wanted to so you met him you worked
with him worked with him recently for
the first time i got my one degree
with him on a funnier die
short that he directed called a duck
walks in
it's about this love scene that kevin
bacon
is directing that involves a duck and it
was such
a surreal thing because part of it was
so kevin which is always a weird thing
when a director has to choreograph like
a sex scene um
and in this case kevin like got into the
bed with me and started going through
all these like
sexual positions with me
and it was so
it was funny it was really fun uh
but at one point i was like whoa kevin
bacon is like lunging at me missionary
and i have my legs spread open like a
missionary it's crazy i gotta see this
oh i did like reverse cowgirl on him
i wish you guys had seen how justin's
head cocked proudly
as you said reverse cowgirl speaking of
nerdy exhales
yeah it was really it was so fun and
like they must have been so surreal it
was you because
the way you have known him for so many
years and oh my god my idea of him as
when i was a kid was that he was i mean
definitely cool because he was like
starring in these cool movies flatliners
and like a lot of movies that i couldn't
watch too so even like she's having a
baby we weren't allowed to watch uh our
movies we were
movies about babies yeah
yeah
but one of our favorite movies was one
that is like a tradition in our family
to watch every thanksgiving is planes
trains and automobiles kevin bacon has a
cameo in that where he um tries to
outrun
steve martin and and it's it's a really
great scene it's a shot sort of like a
sergio leone movie where they're uh it's
a
and they they kind of eye each other
from across it's really impressive oh
thanks
people might think that that was just
put in no that was justin's whistle
thank you
thanks
i'm a great whistler
uh i am i like to whistle do you know
that about me i whistle often to myself
i whistle a lot
did you know that i've noticed that yeah
i've never heard you proclaim it though
oh yeah oh i've been noticing because
i've spent more time on my own in the
last year
ladies he's single
he's a great whistler maybe that's kept
me
on my own and you know we should
since we did this interview we've
christian i've been saying wwkb
uh stands for what would kevin bacon do
d
w
kb oh right d i missed the letters
oh kevin bacon
[Laughter]
what would kevin bake
and coming up right after the break
my interview with kevin bacon life could
be a dream sweetheart
hello hello
you know i picked up the guitar
as a writing tool
when you were i remember you told me
when you were really really young yeah
um it's interesting that you wanted to
write songs before i did music yeah
that's interesting yeah
wha
why when what did your brother and you
because he was older and he was playing
in the house and i was listening to him
right sounds like you know your older
brother you looked up to him yeah i
looked up to him yeah yeah yeah is
christian older than you he's younger
but i still look up to him
he's funnier
and i look up but i we do have an older
brother as well and
he's also very i look up to him too i
look up to a lot of people i definitely
look up to you
i keep i've realized that i keep using
the word thrilling like when somebody
comes in i'm like this is a thrill to
talk to you i was i'm getting paranoid
that i'm overusing the word but
i think this this is it's okay that this
is thrilling to me because i
i grew up loving movies i grew up um and
loving movies i grew up in the 80s and
there
that's when you were starting out you
would become uh you so when i i grew up
with you as a movie star and so it's odd
to know you now in a different capacity
we started already i think so i hope so
i don't know what if we haven't what if
that's just how i talk
he's changed
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is he
talking about but you were when i saw
you now but why why were we when we were
in albuquerque together we were at a bar
in albuquerque we were at a bar in
albuquerque uh you were shooting well
you were shooting too are you yeah yeah
we were shooting um i was doing a um i
had this idea to do a tremors tv series
and you know i i was thinking about
characters that i'd done that i was
maybe gonna want to revisit uh actually
revisit the characters you know because
they've remade
all the movies that begin with f they've
remade footloose flatliners now they're
doing a friday the 13th clearly about a
million times they've remade it now
they're doing um oh yeah that's true all
the live version of few good men i mean
that's not telling oh yeah but if you
take uh off
yeah if it begins with uh
good man
you know and so i i i thought to myself
i think this would be
i want to see who this guy is after all
these years yeah
and
then he was like grizzled back then yeah
something like that yeah yeah he was
kind of
he was a met i mean he was like a guy
who was kind of stuck in this small town
and i thought well what if 25 years
later you know who who does that person
become
um
and i like the character because i he's
not
really smart and you know how like
everybody when they describe a character
to you they always say he's very smart
that's like almost pretty almost all
character descriptions at least that i
guess not the ones yeah he's
he's he's from the streets but he's very
very smart you know he was raised by
wolves yeah but he's very smart
but this guy not not that smart and um
it must have been fun it's got to be fun
yeah it was fun tremors was a lot of
people think of it uh you know in
retrospect as a successful film but it
really wasn't
uh in the theater in the theaters nobody
went i didn't you did oh good good okay
there was you and the other guy i think
my mom took me so she went as well all
right great all right excellent so it
wasn't a hit but it but it grew a
following it was the time when
the
video thing was really coming alive yeah
and
everybody was like super super into uh
blockbuster and uh renting movies and
there were these kind of movies that
took off and had their own life yeah you
know just on video
and that was one of them and did do what
other movies of yours would you say that
applied oh probably um
that's a good question was flatliners a
hit in the theaters i think flatlanders
did pretty well in the theaters but
probably took off a little bit more on
video by the way i should i should have
prefaced all this by saying we're going
to be mentioning a lot of movies and and
if there are ones that you're unfamiliar
with don't um
you should just see them because these
are all great yeah movies that we're
referencing not ones that i've done um
and i in fact saw i had never seen she's
having a baby i started watching that i
i love your work i love john hughes yes
that did better on that that was much
better on uh video than it was on um uh
in the theaters it's so it's really good
that's a good movie yeah yeah i was i
was proud of that one
it was good and you carry that movie
with elizabeth montgomery she's so she's
so charming and good in it uh a young
alec baldwin right alex first movie it
was yeah no kidding yeah that was his
first movie it's so weird to see him
with the young face but he's still like
smoking like a chimney and he's yeah and
he's still got this kind of like
grizzled attitude yes really yeah yeah
yeah um i don't know when it became uh
part of the zeitgeist but six degrees of
kevin bacon is is something that a lot
of people play because and i think
there's a misconception that that game
six degrees of kevin bacon exists
because
the diverse roles you've played and the
diverse projects you've taken i think it
was just a fluke i think these guys just
saw my picture my they they were
watching it in their college dorm room
and and one of my movies was on and they
just said let's let's play six degrees
at kevin oh really you know the origin
of that i do yeah oh what is it yeah
it's it's three guys uh they were they
were at the uh a college in uh i'm
trying to think with the name of the
school someplace in pennsylvania uh-huh
and they were just hanging out and they
kind of came up with this idea
and
it was in the probably one of the first
things that
really spread in a viral kind of way you
know um so this is 90s
90s yeah early 90s mid early mid 90s and
and i thought was you know i was kind of
horrified by the idea because i i
thought it was a joke at my expense
really you know this this guy's such a
douche bag and but you can connect them
to lawrence olivia you can connect an
app
you can connect sort of like a loser
actor like this to some of the greats in
history and and that's the thing that
really oh and so so when i i was like
you're such a random actor yeah that was
part
yeah
i never
read it that way yeah it had very little
i think to do with me specifically um
other than uh-huh they had just
seen my my picture there also rhymes
with separation does it sort of i mean
it's close kevin bacon separation
and then i met the guys and they were
great they were sweet and it was all it
was all good it is easy to play we were
playing out here we were like and we
weren't playing it but we the movie
forrest gump came up all of a sudden got
paranoid that you would walk in to the
studio as we were talking about forrest
gump and then i realized like oh wait
you you weren't in for a scum which
surprised me because it's not so much
the number of things you've done it's
the that's what i mean it's the quality
it's the it's the things you've done
it's the so many of them are we're
talking about them now tremors
flatliners foot i mean i could name so
many of them
uh were are movies that people know and
i think that's what's rare and that
maybe is what separates that and they
have very big casts
yeah which means that there's more
chances to be connected that's true we
were thinking of creating a game that's
like no degrees of kevin bacon trying to
come up with somebody who is not in a
move trying to come up with a movie in
which none of the actors uh have done
have worked with you
well no that that's not so hard but to
come up with a movie where none of the
actors have worked with somebody that
hasn't worked with me that'd be that'd
be tough that'd be tough yeah i mean the
craziest one i heard uh and and i was
once developing a uh a series about
the booth brothers john wilkes booth
edwin edwin booth oh that'd be great um
is that i i'm actually connected in six
degrees to john wilkes booth
and the way that worked was somebody
that did a play with him was young
enough at the time because clearly there
were no movies at the time but he was
young enough at the time
to have grown up and then uh acted in a
talkie my god and that talk he you know
someone just you know punched it up and
six degrees because six is a long pretty
big number it is yeah edwin booth is a
fascinating thing have you been to the
actors that what is that called it's
it's players club players club yeah i'm
just there for the first time yeah yeah
yeah amazing it was where edwin booth
used to hang out i guess sure
yeah uh he died there i think oh wow
well i just did this answer i mentioned
their sponsor but i'm that's not why i'm
mentioning them ancestry.com um i just
did my thing and i i uh i found out that
my great grandfather i knew none of this
he started a theater in rochester uh
vaudeville theater where they showed and
i and now i'm thinking about all the
people who must have passed through
their you know the chaplains and the
laurel and hardy's yeah yeah and that's
have you ever thought about doing uh uh
tracing back your lineage i did it on
the on the television show finding your
voice oh you did that yeah yeah
uh
cure and i i did it and and we
discovered that we were cousins
so get out of here yeah i'm serious what
yeah
you're a cedric or she's a bacon well i
don't know we're so you know it's it's
it's pretty i mean it's we're pretty far
removed you know i was just about to
praise your relationship with your wife
but now i i should have said with your
cousin yeah i might have a great
relationship with your cousin hey honey
come on over here
uh yeah you guys have been fornicating
for how long
uh holy [ __ ] yeah we're we're
we're distant very distant cousins so
that was that was kind of a big reveal
how did you meet cura this is a good
story yeah we uh your cousin my cousin
kira
yeah there was a play by lanford wilson
called lemon sky which uh is a
real interesting cool play um
and it was being done at the second
stage theater here in new york
and um in the play was jeff daniels and
cynthia nixon and the filmmaker named
jane eagleson
came to that that production and decided
that he wanted to film it for for public
television
jeff and cynthia didn't want to do it
and so that's how cure and i got the the
offer and we we weren't really playing
opposite each other she's kind of like
my um i guess step sister
uh that fits yeah right exactly
[Laughter]
yeah it should have been a uh
it should have been telling on yeah we
would end up being cousins
we were living in cambridge shooting in
boston at wgbh and uh
that's where we met i fell in love
yeah and it happened quickly i mean it's
funny we were just talking about this
those moments
i can't relate to that moment where you
just know that this is going to be oh
[ __ ] i i don't want to be without this
person i think i knew before she did um
at the family reunion yeah right
[Laughter]
but but you know
she eventually
i eventually
you know wore her down thank god because
that jeff daniels didn't do it because
then
you'd be with cynthia nixon that's right
well
somewhere i don't know if that would
have probably happened it wouldn't last
too long
[Applause]
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vied for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wundery app
[Music]
hello hello
we'll meet again
celebrity came to you
it's now you you're almost
famous for being famous so you've been
dealing with it for
a long time dealing with it like an
affliction but well yeah but here's the
thing
when i was on
uh
the soap operas that was the first
little taste that i had right which was
very different because people
who watched soap operas believe that you
were the actual guy oh yeah so people
will come up to me and say tim tim
you've got to be nice to your mother and
and i was a teenage alcoholic so stop
drinking what character did you play
though tim the teenager yeah
yeah um yeah so they'd say stop it stop
drinking be nicer to your mother and
morgan will never love you things like
that you know and
and it's crazy and then that sort of
like you know went away and i had a
little you know but nothing and then
footloose really changed it you know
right then it was like that was 84 that
was 80 yeah i think 83 or 84. so that
was a big big life change what's really
changed a lot out of a thousand people
only one person had a camera all right
and now out of the thousand people a
thousand people have a camera of course
it's a it's these sneak these like
people you know stealthily
and and that's there's something about
that that's a little harder i think to
take you are the youngest of six
siblings were you all close i know
you're very close with your brother yeah
we're close but i'm sort of in the
mistake category because they were they
were you're the youngest i'm the
youngest and they were all a couple of
years between them
and then there were eight years and then
i was born so my closest sibling is
eight years older than me but in my
family there was a tradition of trying
to leave home
you know soon so everybody was out of
the house by like 16 or or 17. why was
that just to get at do you know find
your own road and get to college or
whatever it happens to be where did you
grow up philly oh yeah yeah and uh so by
the time i was eight
everybody was gone oh my god um but that
but still i i am still very close with
him even your older brother with whom
you play uh yeah he's he's 10 years
older than me because of that age
disparity i'm i'm wondering
were you trying to get them to notice
you and to kind of totally yeah yeah
yeah i mean i was an actor before i was
an actor
i was i wanted to be
looked at personally i think actors
should
accept that about themselves and love
that about themselves yeah and yeah
because
because we are the people that are
supposed to do that it's true you seem
very you seem like you have accepted
that in a way that is very
honest and cool and
it's even that story you know just
admitting that like god you know it's
kind of better being
kevin bacon listen
you know
i i
am so grateful to be an actor and to
have an acting career and to be able to
do
what i do not just the not just the fame
part and not just all the other good
stuff that's that's come there's been so
much so much good things that have come
from of course being an actor
but
to be able to get the opportunity to uh
you know
walk in another character's shoes
and to be able to um do the things that
i've done in terms of like just life
experiences i have nothing to gratitude
about being an actor you have one of
those enviable careers where it's you've
gotten to play and that's maybe why
you've gotten to play characters that
are unlike so so many uh of your other
characters it's you know i hate to use
the word chameleon or or a character
actor but like it's i'm a character yeah
that's all i am yeah i mean i you know i
said when i've tried to be the leading
man it's it's never really
worked i mean maybe it worked once but
uh but you know i do you feel less more
comfortable i'm way more comfortable as
a character actor i just to him one of
the first
things that made me decide that i just
wanted to make movies was we had a
little movie theater around the corner
from us in in in philly where they would
show
they were kind of grouped together um
second run movies and you get in there
for a dollar
and they had two dustin hoffman movies
back-to-back and one was uh midnight
cowboy and i went to see that and i was
able to talk might as well because
midnight cowboy i think at the time was
at least it came out as an x but i think
they reduced it to an r and i was only
probably i don't know 12 or something
but somehow i faked my way in there oh
yeah because there's some racy stuff in
that oh yeah yeah definitely with joe
buck yeah with joe buck yeah and and i
saw these two guys i was like jesus
christ that's a cowboy and that's a
homeless guy and then the next one was
the graduate and i went holy [ __ ] that's
the same [ __ ] guy but he's actually a
preppy kid yeah and when i saw that i
went oh well that's what you can do if
you're an actor you can do these two you
can do different things yeah and that
that's completely set me off on a on a
road that's interesting what an idea
what my idea of an actor was supposed to
be this was so such an impressionable
period of your life you went
not to la to pursue movies though i find
it interesting that you went to new york
to do theater yeah
well my mother was born and raised in
new york and even though we grew up in
philly
uh i think she was always kind of
secretly whispering in my ear saying you
gotta get out of here and get to new
york
and my
sister lived in new york my sister karen
and uh stopped trying to get rid of my
mom yeah whispering right here
what's for dinner yeah
but anyway the the wow i came to uh new
york because
i wanted to uh i want to do movies but i
also wanted to do um
theater and i was just really
comfortable in new york and uh new york
l.a was kind of terrifying yeah you know
it was too
even the first time i went out there i
was just scared scared shitless of l.a
just scared to scare the [ __ ] out of me
this is also a time where it's like you
know there's there's a whole health
the cult movement and l.a was synonymous
with things that were probably
so vastly different still is but like
culturally it was such a leap from
i would imagine the east coast it was
and but the other piece of it was we're
talking about 1976 when i moved to
new york so being uh a new york actor
and looking at the movies of scorsese oh
yeah and of uh de palma and um
uh you know uh sidney lamette yeah and
the pacinos and the dineros and the
hoffman's and the streeps and the you
know like this was the this was the this
was this amino yeah this this was the
kind of stuff that i wanted to be part
that makes sense that makes sense that
the gene hackmans and stuff like the pop
boy doyle they were all in it's true
they weren't in
what was la then it was like the beach
boys yeah la was just a little bit more
uh it was more of like where the
television industry is in hollywood and
it was game shows surfing and you know i
mean i i don't know yeah i was like into
a gritty kind of world like i wanted to
be in a gritty world and ride the
subways yeah you know and
working as a waiter you know the whole
yeah that's exactly what i did i mean
that's for a couple years right yeah oh
yeah that was my life you told me about
you did it for a couple years but then
animal house was your first i got the
circle and uh this is circling the
square on the square yeah theater school
yeah i went up there out of out of high
school
um
to uh
to try to
uh be in their summer acting program
which i which i did which was really for
high school kids
and like you looked young
yeah yeah and i said well listen uh can
i audition for your winter program and
they said you're too young to be in the
regular theater school and eventually
they said okay
and
so i i auditioned i got into their
two-year professional workshop they
called it and i started waiting tables
and uh
got cast um
shockingly out of an animal house out of
uh school how did that happen how you
did you have an agent did you i had no
agent there was a uh there was a uh
casting director named michael chinich
who uh
just called up the school and said do
you have any uh
characters that would work as like kind
of preppy um college kids uh-huh and
they sent me over and i met with john
landis and i made some faces basically
for him what do you mean well he just
said he said i make a smarmy face i
didn't know what the word meant so i
made a smarmy face
and i see her smile i was like yeah i
don't know you know he he
and he was like that's it i love that
and uh so i i did that what with and and
and they cast me uh blew my mind i mean
it blew my [ __ ] mind i mean i didn't
have to read anything well i don't
really know there's there were any lines
maybe there was a little bit of dialogue
but there wasn't very much oh oh uh
or and i hadn't seen the script um
and the and the casting director called
me up and he said listen you got that
part and you need to get on a plane and
come out here to uh oregon
and i was like well
i have a date and uh
my laundry is not ready you know he was
like you don't understand you need to we
things have changed we need you here
quickly and you're getting scaled and i
was like okay i didn't know what scale i
didn't know it was why would you not
jump at that why would you not i just
being an [ __ ] you know i don't know i
i was confused i was overwhelmed i mean
i had nobody to explain to me what was
happening it was like i was in a scared
maybe yeah scared scared shitless i was
like okay you're in a movie and you're
leaving
school
and
basically i had to you know drop out and
go and and and do this thing and i it
just was it was [ __ ] scary oh so it
wasn't like it wasn't
thrilling and fear it was that who's
that too yeah yeah it was that too i
mean
i got on uh never forget i was uh my
first time ever on first first class i
didn't realize that in first class
because in those days sag had to fly
your first class like you could drink as
much as you want and that blew my mind
you know i was 18 years old
yeah so i i remember sitting there and
and
just getting completely hammered another
triple took keylesser yeah my god
and in fact i i pulled out the uh script
so that it would look kind of you know
cool yeah and
and by the end of the flight i was
asking the flight attendant to come and
spend the night with me in uh in san
francisco and she she actually said i'm
the pilot sir i took yeah
i decided that
you know once they rolled the uh the
after dinner cart around um
you know they they said uh well you
could have an after you know an after
dinner drink and i decided that um
amaretto was kind of like a classy thing
to order sure and uh so i drank a ton of
amaretto and
she gave me the bottle to take with me
off the plane
and to this day i can't even smell
amaranth oh yeah it's just brutal isn't
that funny i got drunk on red wine once
to the point where i threw up like it
was like a bathtub faucet of red it was
disgusting and i to this i can't uh
anyway um i wonder if that flight
attendant whoever she may be
thinks it remembers that i wonder if she
has any recollection of like oh that's
that's funny right before you get to the
animal house i keep propositioning me
i'm sure she doesn't remember fondly
yeah punk yeah i was a punk yeah it
sounds like this is testament to how
much somebody can change and grow and
over one's short life because you seem
like the opposite of that guy now so
like considerate and grounded and
listen you don't like amaretto yeah
people change yeah
wow so when you get up there what what
do you attribute that to i mean
just having been in i i would imagine
that type of person then going into
movies and getting to star and be in
movies that's probably not a great
combination and i'm sure you've seen it
happen to a lot of people where they go
the other way they become [ __ ] yeah
yeah i mean how did you not how did you
become another i think i think my
parents were um
were
good decent um hard-working people yeah
um i also think that
i was so
so you had a work ethic you had a really
strong worth work ethic yeah and i was
so driven
that i never took things to the point
where
i would risk it getting in the way of my
dreams
so if it was booze or drugs or
you know you know on set behavior or
throwing tantrums or or you know uh yeah
be getting too wrapped up in the fame
and the whole whole kind of thing i i
just instinctually
knew that i never wanted it to go and
get in the way of my uh my dreams that
that that yeah and you could see it
veering you could tell when it was going
to when it was in danger of doing that
yeah and there were cautionary tales all
around me you know and there
still are you know it's like i say
there's a lot of roadkill when you know
people it start out at the same time as
you and yeah you know you look you know
down the road and then you know there's
a lot of people that just oh [ __ ] i've
seen it i mean i've been at it for 20
years i've seen it happen but i can only
imagine what you see especially during
the excesses of the 80s like
talking about an animal house yeah it
was crazy well i mean you know that's
such an iconic movie too you know but
also in terms of you know exploring
those excesses maybe indulging and did
you know who john blue she was before
sure yeah because he was a roche star
yeah he was he was a star yeah and he
and and of course he was the biggest
star yeah in the film and um
you know snl had this kind of incredible
mystique especially even in new york you
know it felt like
it was even more new yorky you know snl
you know we'd
any any bar you'd be in on a saturday
night they'd turn the everything down
and turn up snl you know it was it was a
very it was a very iconic kind of thing
and he was at his at his peak and he was
coming back and forth from the show oh
that's right yeah yeah to oregon yeah so
that was uh it was something else i bet
i was telling somebody this story the
other day that uh they were asking me
about belushi and
he wasn't staying at the hotel we were
staying at you know some crappy hotel
and by the side of the road and he had a
house and uh
he had a party
for um the cast
and uh probably midway through or
something like that maybe towards the
end of the shoot
and
it blew my mind because first off the
idea that he would have uh the
generosity and also the coin to throw a
party for everybody and then
he had brought uh smoked salmon
from new york like you know locks like
from from from
zabar's or barney greengrass or whatever
and it brought it out to oregon that
blew my mind because to me first off
lox was one of the most expensive things
you could get like like like a like a
bagel you know with cream cheese was
whatever 75 cents or whatever it was a
bagel with cream cheese and lunch was
like five or six bucks
so the idea that there was this giant
mound of locks
and also it was the first time that i'd
ever heard of or had a mimosa and like
that was so interesting to me
oh my god you're taking this champagne
and putting it in ours this is [ __ ]
cool
i i really want to be a star yeah
[Music]
life could be a dream sweetheart
i really have always been curious about
that iconic scene in a few good men
watching that
um you can't handle the truth scene it's
a scene that gets like people it's
almost it's been parodied beyond belief
now like to death uh
what was it like what was it like being
there in the amazing amazing uh and a
great great lesson for um actors and
acting and um you know in general very
inspirational um
because
uh you know not to get too technical but
when you shoot a scene like that you're
you're kind of shooting in one direction
right yeah and
generally what you do which i think we
did is we started pretty wide on on uh
the backs of our heads and and and with
with jack in the in the in the deep
background and then they start to kind
of you know get closer and closer and
closer on on him kevin's playing the
prosecuting attorney yeah i'm i'm the
prosecuting attorney and uh jack
nicholson is on the uh is on the stand
so if you can picture you know
he's on the stand and then facing him is
is me and and tom cruise and demi moore
and kevin pollock
you know nicholson
again one of those
like super super uh important actors to
me he was the first actor i think that i
thought to myself
he doesn't give a [ __ ] if anybody thinks
he's an [ __ ] yeah and to me that was
really yeah kind of like
new and intangible it was one thing to
be a bad guy
or to be a flawed hero or something like
that yeah again it was one of those yeah
things like you're watching and i'm
watching it i'm watching an icon yeah
and i don't get that a lot with actors
frankly i get a lot more with with rock
stars but but in the case of him i i
i really did and and he delivered this
speech and we were like um i was like
holy [ __ ] that's good whoa and then
another take and then another size and
then another this is the other side of
the truth speech yes we live in a world
that has walls yeah yeah it's a great
speech great speech and uh uh aaron's
working obviously great white writer and
uh you know it you know
one take after another after another and
close up and close up now we got to turn
around right on the rest of us
and so he started to undo his uniform
and his hair started to get a little
messed but didn't really matter because
he wasn't on camera anymore and you know
eventually it was like his you know
uniforms t-shirt you know he's looking
more like nicholson right yeah
but he just kept delivering that speech
for every single one of us on tom's
close-up the means close-up but michael
said but kev
just looks like again and again and
again i thought to myself okay
so this guy
he could be in his trailer at this point
yeah you know he was that big of a star
too yeah i mean he could have gone he
could have driven right off the lot and
so it wasn't even just the off camera as
it was the uh intensity that he was able
to commitment yeah so i i always uh
respected him and appreciated that that
is a really that's a really cool story
um now your kids are actors you've
raised two two kids well no my
daughter's an actor my son's not an
actor he's a musician so wow yeah yeah
where'd that come from yeah exactly yeah
um what is that like raising kids as
recognizable people raising kids who
underst i mean perhaps i would imagine
they understand the pitfalls of what of
that world a little bit better than most
i think they do we never steered them
towards uh this it's something that they
had to you know discover on our own my
daughter like roxy really resisted i
knew she was going to be good but she
pushed it back for a long time until it
was her decision so
and my son was a little different only
because he he really that's all he ever
was doing from the time he was a tiny
little kid he was like playing guitar
and yeah so you knew right i mean i knew
i knew right i knew he had to have a
life in music how did you know with your
daughter what did you recognize uh i
just had a sense that she was going to
be good at it but she told me that she
didn't that that while she thought it
was okay she wasn't really into it and
she was off on a whole other kind of
life that was a little heavier kind of
academic and
finally when she made the switch and
decided to do it
i said what happened to the all that
stuff about how it's not for you and she
said
well i was just saying what i thought
you wanted me to hear oh i thought what
you wanted to hear interesting and i
guess that somehow my wife and i had
you know intentionally are not kind of
giving her given her the impression that
we didn't really want her to do this as
a career well that makes sense you know
isn't it you know being judged a
lifetime of rejection totally uh you you
know you you're constantly told no
the the chances of making it as an actor
are slim to none yeah there's so much of
this garbage there of course that really
you kind of go ahead yeah you don't want
your kid this weekend i really want my
kids to you know be exposed to this so
it's amazing that this would be coming
from two successful act two of the
actors who have you know reached the
heights that most actors 99.9 don't but
i i get it i interior what's really cool
though now is that we have a dialogue
that uh
we never really had before because you
know my kids never watched
um our movies we never talked about the
business very much it's not something
that we spent time around the dinner
table
for many many years we never took them
into public wait what we did well we
were talking about we just didn't take
to like red carpet kind of okay
it was like we kept them in the air no
no no no we kept them in the basement no
any kind of public situations like you
know where there were going to be
photographers
kept them from that so we never had a
dialogue about it so
um now we can actually talk about uh
what was that like shooting that thing
so cool
or you know now she'll actually go back
and and uh
watch watch your films or or
you know what should i do about
you know this audition and you know i
don't know you know what like that we
can actually discuss that's really nice
yeah so it's cool and your son i'm sure
with music you can do that yeah i know
same thing with him yeah yeah um what
how do this is
feel free to answer this but i'm curious
how you stay happily married how you
state what i don't know man what is
there any secret they know that i can't
even like it really isn't you know when
the people ask me that uh they often
phrase it with it's got to be a lot of
work right
you know heart relationships are hard
work aren't they and i say actually it's
really more about play we don't look at
it as work yeah yeah we i always wonder
that like why should it be work i mean
this thing should be easy i i thought
that about the relationships i've been
in the ones that have worked and not
worked and the ones that have worked
have always been there's some there's an
ease to them in a sense i get that a
sense of play obviously they didn't work
long enough for outside right
listen i hesitate sometimes to talk
about the this because
you know i don't want to say one thing
there is no one thing of course that's
number one number two
marriages don't work look at them they
don't work so so don't beat yourself off
if it doesn't work and
and you know the the the odds are
pretty slim um but if you
someday hopefully you find somebody that
that you can spend time with yeah that's
cool i'm glad because i i like you both
i'm glad that you are in that situation
uh
last question before we get into the
really short lightning round uh thank
you for taking all the time uh i know
you've been a big proponent of the
separation of church and state um what
is your relationship like with religion
now i don't have religion um
divorced i would like
i would love to tell you if i'm agnostic
or atheist but i i i can never figure
out the difference between the two and
it's a funny place to be in
in this world and in this country and at
in this time and it comes up for me
a lot more now than it used to in that
um
you realize when you don't believe in
god that so much is is done and said and
and and moves are made and votes are
cast and things are
discussed and all with the framework of
uh
you know religion yeah but there is a
level of kind of outsiderness to that
yeah that makes sense how do you then
feel about the afterlife or any sort of
uh
do you believe
this is it as far as i'm concerned oh
yeah yeah and you're okay with that yeah
i'm done wow i mean i've even said to
wow my wife my family i said listen
just know you know if if uh if if if the
curtain comes down i've had a great life
and that's it that's been good i'm done
you don't you don't stay awake thinking
about it
no
no i mean maybe i will
but closer when you get closer to me
yeah i mean everyone finds it good right
right yeah right before this oh wait a
minute yeah yeah i changed my mind um no
i don't uh i don't i don't i don't think
that way so to when you're having these
conversations let me just say by the way
that i i also
do not
uh
begrudge or
uh uh disrespect anybody who does have
religion or has a spiritual life or has
any kind of i'm kind of jealous of them
that they yeah anything that they that
they want to do and explore
as as as long as it's not you know
they're not hurting people in the name
of god or excluding people or
discriminating against people or
discriminating against me because i
don't believe you know what i mean it's
like that's the whole thing that's the
whole thing other than that you know you
can you know do whatever you want man
you so you weren't raised religious
enough no my mother went to church um
actually the first place i ever well the
first place i ever acted was in her
church believe it or not we were
pretending to be uh
no it's not that i just i don't know she
was she liked going to church she yeah
for her it was really more of a
community
kind of thing my father was raised as a
quaker but he kind of turned his back on
the meeting uh when he was a pretty
young man and and i don't
i'm not exactly sure what his spiritual
beliefs were an attractive young man um
what uh what is your most commonly used
emoji
uh bacon
oh yeah
i i sign a sign with that it took me
too long to put that together yeah
that's a good one that is a course yeah
oh you must have been so excited when
they came out with it yeah it was um
i love that you do that that's [ __ ]
great
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play i like to i
would like to play basketball if i'm
terrible as uh i'm awful i just like it
i just like i just uh you know actually
i'm really more of a knicks fan yeah you
know i i really didn't get into
basketball and being a fan until i had
moved to new york it was like in the 80s
yeah you know gorgeous you know time for
new york basketball yeah great ewing and
oakley and yeah you and oakley starks
yeah have fun
and all of them yeah and uh you know
games yeah yeah yeah yeah um
if you could have one snack food for the
rest of your life what would it be oh
snack food yeah you're like go-to you're
stoned if you smoke and um
this is gonna sound so
hippy dippy but i would have to say
almonds oh no i mean just because they
to me they kind of have everything
protein and wow and what a guilty
pleasure i know i'm sorry it's
embarrassing i thought you're going to
say like brazil nuts even no
that would be too outrageous
calm down
uh what is your favorite movie of all
time if you had to pick one i had to
pick one movie of all time i'd say
this is spinal tap oh god yeah did you
ever say you're surrounded by all these
instruments [ __ ] by the way you got to
work with those guys well with
christopher christopher yeah chris chris
directed me in a great movie called big
picture which is so good on kind of an
unsung hero of a movie it is it's um
why why is that movie not lasted his
other movies have
reached cult status well interestingly
enough it was not
he's he did it before he kind of uh but
he had he had worked on spinal tap but
you know as an actor rob because rob
reiner directed
right
um and then
it was before he had moved into the
mockumentary kind of side of things yeah
that was scripted it was scripted yeah
um but i i
you know if if you're
if you work in hollywood or even if you
don't work in hollywood it is it's
really holds up it's so good and i can't
tell you how many times i'm in
situations that remind me of the big
picture because it's so realistic it's
so i mean it's very realistic yeah which
is probably where he kind of learned to
do that move into that mockumentary
thing yeah i wish she had put you in
some of those uh i have a bone to pick
with him i'll save it for his yeah so
he'd be good uh god
people should see that um
if you had to live somewhere else uh
where would it be between aside from new
york or l.a where you live now oh aside
from new york or l.a uh
i guess maybe uh
uh seattle oh yeah yeah
i i had wanted to go there and i'd never
been and now i
do that much more uh if you could have
dinner with three people dead or alive
whom you've never met who who three
people dead or realized
sorry i guess i'd say
john lennon
maybe all right um there we go yeah uh
i'd like to have dinner you were one of
mine
i picked you wow john lennon uh
martin luther king
um
and uh
junior or senior
yeah um
what is your name ruth ruth
ruth yeah uh she's in the dead category
yeah yeah well she could she could join
ruth bacon uh
what did she do for a living she was a
nursery school teacher and then uh
taught uh child early childhood
education she
um
[Music]
and
right before she died she was involved
with um working in the uh prison system
in philadelphia and and uh when the
during visiting hours of the the
prisoners had wives and kids that would
come and visit she she kind of created
these play rooms so that they wouldn't
just be in a situation where where um
they were just exposed you know plastic
chairs at tables there was like stuff to
do
and they could actually interact with
the kids and stuff what a great speaking
of legacy yeah she was she was amazing
uh who's your favorite muppet
you know what pops into my head is yeah
ernie not ernie uh
you know uh kermit just because i love
that song it's not easy yeah it's just
such a great song yeah um he kills it
man vocal vocals are fantastic
on that
banjo um on the lily pad uh if you'd
have one superpower what would it be
i would say invisibility uh-huh oh yeah
ironic yeah as from coming from the man
who played the invisible man um
uh with elizabeth shu was that right
elizabeth schuh and josh brolin rona
mitra uh ronamitra yeah and uh directed
by uh paul verhoeven that's right um uh
okay uh dogs or cats um
more dogs i'm a dog person um
beetle stones
uh
you know
gosh
i guess i'm
god that's a that's a really tough one i
[Music]
i guess probably i'm a little bit more
of a stones fan
um i could see that yeah but uh i know
it's hard to say it's yeah not it's hard
to
say something about the beatles in a
negative way like not the beatles yeah i
mean listen there's nothing wrong with
the beatles it'd be really awkward for
your dinner with lennon and your mom i
know it would be awkward you know it
came up it's just that the
it's just that
i'm just a little bit more just a little
like the i like the edge a little bit i
don't know well the bacon brother
there's there's a bluesy edge to what
you think there's a little bluesy yeah
they're a little bluesier yeah
i i mean listen like i could listen to
them i know both of those bands
intimately and yeah so i i
i not nothing the beatles under the bus
well you shouldn't because you know we
had paul mccartney on and he actually
said was bacon brothers or williams and
he picked the bacon brothers so um uh
you have a charity this is just one of
the last thing um you have a charity
called
sixdegrees.org.org uh can you describe
what what i just decided to take the six
degrees thing and and try to do
something positive with it and uh you
know we've had a lot of kind of
iterations but one of the things that
that uh we've done a lot of is
going into uh
really small grassroots kind of
organizations that don't get a lot of
exposure um in big you know fundraising
chicken dinner you know
whatever galas gallows yeah
and there's a lot of them out there yeah
all the way across the country yeah
sometimes we i i'm able to drop in on
these things when i'm on on the road
with the band because
uh we happen to be in you know nashville
or wherever where the these these places
are
um more local charities local kind of
yeah smaller things and and we just kind
of come through and um see what they're
doing
you know maybe there'll be some media
maybe there'll be an enough
possibility to do some shout outs on
social and and try to just give them a
little bit more of a boost and a
leg up i mean i just went with um al
this hodge who's uh my co-star on uh
city on a hill and when we found
uh this place called the door down and
actually right right uh across town here
um which is this fantastic organization
has been there for probably i don't know
35 years and they they work with uh kids
you know as a as a place to go and and
they have uh music and they have theater
and they have dance and they have um
help with homework and school and they
have health services and it's just a
place for kids who are a little bit lost
in in our in our new york you know
system to go and have a place to go
something your mom would probably really
appreciate she would love it she would
love this place yeah that's cool yeah
well i um thank you for amplifying those
causes using your voice and mostly for
being selfishly just thank you for being
here oh yeah this is a this is a thrill
really fun really fun yeah what's the
website for the tour dates uh
baconbros.com baconbros.com yeah um do
people ever throw bacon at you when
you're on stage never happened but we
have had people show up dressed as bacon
um a young woman uh was dressed as bacon
and
we asked her to come up and join us on
the finale and interestingly enough she
was very uncomfortable she she was she
was very happy to be dressed as bacon
yeah but she was not at a distance at a
distance yeah she didn't want to be part
of the show yeah you would think
whoever's going to wear an outfit of
bacon would be
you know would want to be seen you'd
think um well uh you are my favorite
bacon oh thank you and um thank you for
for doing this for being here it's been
fun man yeah thanks for listening
[Music]
guys well that just baconed
happened sorry
remember in the beginning when you said
that your goal was going to be to not
gush
yeah and b2 that i do
no no you did well actually
restrained on your part because i knew
how excited you were and i knew how you
know yeah believe it or not really was
believe it or not that was me holding
back
if you heard that and you were like calm
down but there were a few parts when i
heard it back i was like oof you're like
a giddy school girl at times you know
you're so excited by the things he was
saying but i think that's fine i stand
by that it's thrilling to talk to him
the childhood me was i you know you
don't really outgrow a lot of that stuff
no also we should mention that he
mentioned
that he's
listening to the show we have to be a
little careful not to sound too uncool
and too she said i was like a school
girl
thanks
kevin i'm not i don't i don't really
care
i don't think you're that cool no
you're fine uh that story that he told
about uh
flying first class for the first time
when he went out to do uh animal house
is so good but
where he was trying he had this kind of
bravado and he's you know ordering
drinks and hitting on the you know the
stewardess and
that attempt to be he was trying so to
be cool he was trying to be cool yeah
and now
he's clearly so naturally cool and he
has this ease about him i wonder when
and how exactly that happened going from
trying to be cool to being cool how do
you
it's impossible and i'm sure it's he's
too cool to answer that too he's not
going to be self-aware i'm sure it was a
process he was like 18 years old when
that happened right but he was closer to
the guy in foursome yeah oh god that's
sewn something down
but it was interesting that at any point
in his life
even as an 18 year old he was capable of
that kind of
uncool behavior you know trying so hard
no but i think so many people that age
are i mean what what 18 19 year old
isn't you know yeah except maybe timothy
chalamet
that's very well save it for the show
the two two-part chalamet
extravaganza so you asked him how he
avoided
some of the pitfalls that a lot of those
especially in the 80s some of those
actors um you know a lot of those
cautionary tales
and he credited his parents yeah he said
well i was raised i was raised
to be a hard worker and to be you know
respectful and if there was any danger
of that 18 year old kid who's getting
drunk on the plane and
if there's any danger of that guy being
an [ __ ] growing up to be an [ __ ]
i think he was saved by his upbringing
which sounds like his parents sound kind
of
great they do and they sound like they
really let the kids like fly and like
spread their wings and experience the
world and he came to appreciate his
parents in a way that uh after having
seen a lot of the world and also from
you see
what [ __ ] how many [ __ ] there are
out there especially in hollywood
i identified because he talked about
looking up to his older siblings to his
older brothers yeah and i said i was the
youngest and i am the youngest and i
could identify with that and you follow
them and you you admire them
and i mean the difference in his family
is that he talked about how they all you
know left at age 16 because they were so
independently minded and we weren't we
weren't quite that's why we're not
bacons but
one of many reasons but there's this but
there is uh a similarity to that you
know um
and now look what happened he's got this
band with his older brother who he
always admired and they wrote music
together and i feel like we're doing
this thing together which is
yeah you know it i know i see a lot of
yeah we're like we're like the nerdy bit
like four men like canadian bacon
brothers
we're the non-canadian bacon brothers
yeah i know we're the uh what's another
meat that we'd be comparable to because
the prosciutto brothers the sopracetto
brothers oh god oh boy
that wasn't a very kevin bacon thing you
said no it was not
he made me so nostalgic when he was
talking about renting movies from
blockbuster oh i know that
i mean he he i mean in general brings me
back to such a specific time in my life
to being a kid and yeah just the act of
picking out movies you're right i
associate him with that time uh because
he was on a lot of those i love just
looking at the box covers was fun so
cool and his face was i remember seeing
specifically on like she's having a baby
and flatliners his face was so
cool to me i i
i thought of him as um certainly from
plain strands automobiles has like i was
intimidated by his face because it was
it was
so different than mine that's why when
he talked about getting cast an animal
house when he said he he just made faces
yeah like he had him look smarmy or
something he and he does he has such a
naturally
yeah which is odd because he's so nice
sweetie i know he doesn't he doesn't act
like he looks i mean he looks like he
might be a real dick i know and when i
met him that night with a couple friends
um i was sort of bracing myself for a
different kind of person he was talking
about his marriage and uh and i loved
what he said about it i loved how he
didn't offer any specific advice when
he's like there's no secret it's just i
mean the one thing he did that was at
all specific was it's it's more about
play than work yeah and and but he also
said i love that he said this he said
you know this is really rare it's really
hard and if you if something doesn't
work out if you're if you get divorced
if your marriage doesn't work that's
okay because like don't basically don't
feel bad about it don't get down about
it because it's really [ __ ] hard to
have a relationship work so he but he
didn't have this attitude about it like
right like he was speaking from a po
like authority exactly or this uh all
this knowledge that he had about it was
he made it sound like he kind of got
lucky yeah and he it wasn't so much
something he did that was so special
just that he happened to be in a really
good situation it's especially admirable
that they've
they're able to like make their
relationship work because they're both
still they've been such good looking
people for so long you know it's not
like
at a certain point it's like okay well
now we're just like old together and
they're still like such attractive
people
i just remembered he was listening oh my
god oh [ __ ] i forgot to
when he talked about basketball at the
end he said um he said you know i'm a
knicks fan i go to knicks games and i
could feel yeah the excitement and and
and the uh and and the desire to ask him
to go to a game so you're like oh i go
to knicks games too yeah and there's
just pause and i thought for sure you
were gonna be like oh we should go
together sometimes i
obviously almost did finally i'm gonna
say i love that his favorite emoji is
bacon and
and when you said that your favorite
that that he's your favorite bacon
it sounds like [ __ ] because
i know how much you love bacon yeah you
do you
you had bacon today about two hours ago
yeah i saw you eat bacon and i saw you
enjoy it a lot
so for you to say that he's your
favorite bacon sounds
like hyperbole but
i'm i'm here to tell you guys that it's
not yeah i love it you love it i love
him in fact i just met somebody who
doesn't like bacon not kevin the food
and i i couldn't believe it that's how
much i like bacon i was like incredi now
i'm blanking on who it was but somebody
claimed they didn't who was that i don't
know it's like the meatloaf thing though
it's like if you could either give up
meatloaf the food or meatloaf the singer
for the rest of your life what would you
give up and or ah yeah this would if you
could give a bacon or kevin bacon
that means you can never watch a kevin
bacon movie never hear a bacon brother
song never hear a bacon brother song uh
well see now with the meatloaf
question
uh uh a year and a half ago i would have
said i would have given up meatloaf the
singer
uh but then i saw the musical bat out of
hell which is coming to new york guys
you should check it out i saw it twice
in london
once by myself i went by myself the
second time to see it it was so good and
reminded me how great some of those
songs were so i now would say i would
give up meatloaf the food and i'm also
not i like meatloaf the food a lot but
it's not i don't have a lot of it it's
not not crazy about it it'd be nice to
eat one less meat it'd be tough to give
up bacon the food i gotta say i mean i
love kevin bacon but you give up kevin
bacon the actor he's listening remember
uh if i could keep canadian bacon
no i can't no i could have i could have
ham you can have you can have other
nationalities bacon i could have sausage
saudi arabian bacon anyway that was that
was uh that was a thrill i would
definitely kevin uh i want you to know i
would give up the food
bacon he's great he's great we like him
very much i tolerate him
he's fine we of course thank him for
coming on and thank you guys for
listening and um
we are getting your emails right into
life is short at wondery.com and uh keep
them coming keep the suggestions and the
stories uh we're gonna start reading
them soon out loud you've already read
them to ourselves right right right so
you can hear yeah it does you no good if
we're just to know that we're reading
them uh unless you wrote one and uh but
so know that we are reading them and uh
thanks for listening
to life is short
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
thanks for listening guys to life is
short if you enjoyed the show
kevin bacon wouldn't beg for five star
reviews you wouldn't even ask no he
wouldn't bring it up having said that
please give us five stars please again
not a kevin bacon thing to do but please
spread the word tell your tell your
friends um we're available on apple
podcast spotify google podcast
and every major listening app life is
short as hosted by me justin long it's
he wouldn't even say that he wouldn't
brag about me
produced by christian long and megan
monaco senior producers michelle lanz
audio engineers marcelino villapando
it's executed produced by marshall louis
and on lopez for wondering
[Music]
all right that's an interesting idea
that uh
are they're cool out of the blue you
just looked at me and you're like you
know
there's gonna be people who really hate
you
yeah it just occurred to me that
that's like uh
oh my god it's so tangy it's good
it's delicious right it's so tiny it's
almost too too tangy to eat doesn't it
uh i don't think it's too thin
whoa
i'm pretty tangy it's so tangy to me
it's good
but it's like citrusy yeah and it's like
it's mostly lime juice yeah it's like i
feel like
like my lips are puckering eating this
um yeah it's like it's like a third lime
juice
trolls are still good it's good
delicious
trolls might be um
cooler on like an apple site or
like because you don't have to go
through that much to just post on a
thing
that guy sucks yeah you know what that
is crazy i would never do that to anyone
it's just like a shitty
like i don't think um
people who are mean like like uh overtly
mean for no reason to to strangers
or to anybody that's not cool uh it's
not cool behavior like i think that not
only not your behavior it
just disqualifies someone yeah in my
opinion from some that i would ever care
about or so when i say cool i mean like
there's got to be a
like a humane element yeah that's true
for them to be considered cool to me
yeah it's like inhumane i don't [ __ ]
control even like like harrison ford is
hard part of the reason why i don't
think he is cool
because he does because
i mean obviously his characters are
great but he he seems like a [ __ ]
curmudgeon
yeah also case in point someone like
if keanu reeves was like a shitty like
kind of like a [ __ ] like steven
seagal yeah
i wouldn't think he's cool no even
though he's good looking in like cool
movies no but the fact that keanu reeves
like
writing his subway
yeah that's true like
being a good person goes
that's true
so like
anyone who doesn't hate hate buddy
publicly
that's true
you